un message d' alerte les débris de
petite taille de répercuter le nord de
l'état de new york via la donne
vous n'êtes pas là
et
c
on attend ça
il est
la seule chose dont les gens parlent
aujourd'hui c'est clark la comète ainsi
un délai clark et la une des médias
grosse info je vois pas clark
il est peut-être en train de dormir papa
elle est le gros fragment de la comète
clark vont très bientôt entrer dans
notre atmosphère
tout à fait et il ya des soirs de fortes
charges toujours parce que le spectacle
soit impressionnant ou est ce qu'il vaut
joe sérère un des premiers morceaux va
s'écraser s'écraser un petit morceau et
ce sera dans l'océan 2 non mais regardez
ça
eh ben ça n'a pas explosé
[Musique]
nous venons d'apprendre que le fragment
vient de percuter le centre de la
floride
attendez il va y en avoir encore
d'autres
allez viens on se regarde nous y allions
deux jours ils ont dit des conneries il
y aura d'autres fragments qui vont
détruire la terre les agences spatiales
part d'une possible extradition
on va affronter son ensemble auquel
grand faut juste qu'on trouve un refuge
[Musique]
des avions militaires volver des bunkers
au groenland c'est notre seule chance
ok je l'assumé
à lutter oui papa on veut trouver
c'est le plus gros fragment de clark va
c'est gravé dans moins de vingt quatre
heures je le jure je vais conduire ma
famille dans ce bunker je suis sûr
fiston si vous entendez ce message
chercher un refuge immédiatement
qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu est ce qui se
passait j'entendais ce message est radié
accroche-toi aux attentes
si médiatisé cherché partout
il m'a accusé